Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Hope.
For the last 10 days we've been collecting metaphors
and I kind of need to do a day
where we kind of gather all these up.
Alright? Now, I know some people are really not
of a personality that like that sort of thing.
They're not metaphor people, right? They want ultra clarity.
They want a bullet point list.
They are like engineers and accountants, right?
They want the clearest possible list of requirements.
Give me ambiguity
or give me something else, is not really their rallying cry.
So they just went later, like,
gimme the specs and I'll build it.
Well, here's the thing. God doesn't usually work that way,
and he really never has.
Jesus in fact, did the opposite.
They said, look, who is my neighbor? Give the bullet list.
And Jesus told a story. They said, who are you?
And he gave them word pictures.
They insisted that he give his qualifications.
And he told another story.
They said, what's the kingdom of heaven like?
And he told another one. The reason is
because he wants to be pursued in a glorious growing
multifaceted walk with you.
So we've been gathering these metaphors from the scripture,
which are really just pictures of holiness that are meant
to spark our imaginations and teach us what holiness is
and inspire us to long to have it.
So let's review and let's just collect those metaphors.
Holiness means that
after salvation, you continue to become
who you really are as a child of God.
That's Romans six. It means that there is a fuller,
greater cleansing after salvation that's available for you.
Two Corinthians seven. One.
It means that they're still waiting for you
and tiredness, a completion of fullness
of the sanctifying work
that the Holy Spirit began at the new birth.
That's one Thessalonians.
It means that there is a filling of the Holy Spirit
that is greater after salvation.
That's Acts two and Acts four.
It means that there is a cleansing of the idols of the heart
and a softening of the stony heart given by the presence of
that indwelling Holy Spirit.
That's Ezekiel chapter 36.
And it means that there is a greater control
of the Holy Spirit that is deeper, similar to the control
of wine over the body.
That's Ephesians five 18.
This deeper cleansing that God does in us is available
through a deeper surrender of self, even after salvation.
That's Romans six, right?
And a faith that God will accept the
living sacrifice that we offer.
That's Romans 12.
And that God will unite our divided
and selfish hearts to love him wholeheartedly.
That's Psalm 86 11. That's what it means.
That's what we're following. That's the holiness.
Now, someone might say, oh, that's just confusing.
I just, all this confusing. No, no, that's not confusing.
That's sparkling and glorious and multifaceted and exciting.
It is deeper than you can grasp with a simple pamphlet
and a syllogism on the back of a business card, right?
I could put it, I could put it incredibly simply
and sum it up theologically, your heart is still sinful
after salvation, but Jesus died
and the Holy Spirit comes to deal with that sinfulness.
So you should surrender your cleansed body and heart
and believe that he'll keep his promise
to cleanse your heart and you will receive the fullness
of the Holy Spirit by faith.
And then you will follow
that holiness you've received forever,
wherever it takes you, and it'll transform
and grow your character continually.
And eventually it'll walk you directly into the presence
of God in the holiness and glory of heaven.
But while all that is incredibly simple, it's also rich
and textured and beautifully complex.
We could meditate it for hours of video and reams of paper
and you know what scholars
and the saints of all the ages have.
So in the next few days, we're gonna start tackle
tackling some specific distinctions, right?
So what are we supposed to surrender?
Uh, what is purified in this filling of the Holy Spirit?
What is it that I should expect to change or in my life
or in my emotions?
What about my mind? Is it gonna help me think better?
Things like that. But today I just wanted to kind
of help you in case you didn't appreciate the beauty
and sparkle of what we just did.
Alright, the last few days, somebody said once that, um,
that the scripture is like a jewel.
And the more you turn it, the more facets you see.
And the truth is that one angle on a,
on a cut diamond isn't enough.
Right? When it moves, there's a flash and a sparkle
and it, it catches the light and breaks it
and throws it in new ways.
And I just wanna tell you, um, that this,
this holiness is not a bullet list I can give you
and say, here's the bullet list.
Now go put that on a business card and,
and, uh, check that list off.
No. Instead, what we've done, what we've done
for the last few days, is to turn the jewel
and let it sparkle and let it catch the light
and throw it to us in new and colorful and flashing ways.
And so, um, that's what I, I hope
that you've gathered outta the last few days
that it made you, it sparked your imagination,
showed you some new facets,
and inspired you to long to be holy as God has provided.
Alright, thanks. See you tomorrow.
And we'll start talking about the rest of it.